Hello and welcome to another episode of
What's Up Prof. Walter. Hi. What are we
doing?
Causing trouble.
It seems to be our etiquette.
Yes.
It's quite a provocative little picture
that we have here.
And uh
I think those people running on the left
side of the screen
need to practice some dietary reform.
Yeah, maybe when they're on the opposite
side, it could look a little bit
different. Well, there is a line to run
across. I see it. It's not quite getting
there yet. They'll have to take a jump.
Well, it's a leap of faith. It's a leap
of faith, yes.
Let's ask God to help us do this.
Our heavenly Father, we are privileged
to be here and we ask now
for guidance in this discussion.
It's not always an easy one, so we ask
that you enlighten our minds and also
the viewers and help with the Holy
Spirit. In Jesus' name, amen. Amen.
Martin, we've spoken very often about
this issue. Mhm.
And we have used many Bible texts to
show that this is a biblical principle.
For sure.
It is an opening statement in the Bible
as to what the original diet of man was.
And there's a
long explanation as to why the diet of
humanity changed.
Mhm.
Then in the typological studies, there
are many cases in the Bible where God
calls his people back to the original.
It was not so in the beginning was one
of the statements that Jesus made. Yeah.
Now, that didn't refer to diet per se,
but it applies. Mhm.
Cuz if you want to know what it was
like, then you have to go to the
beginning. That's it. But we're not
living in Genesis now, we're living in
Revelation. And Revelation is the
antithesis
of Genesis. In Genesis, everything was
lost. In Revelation, everything is
gained.
Yes. Everything that was lost there has
to be restored. That includes the diet.
And that's so important because if you
want to go and live happily in heaven
with God,
then obviously
if you're not doing the things that will
be heavenly there,
how will you enjoy it? I know a lady who
lives in the Cape and she has pets.
And these pets are sheep.
And these sheep all have names and they
live in the house as well. They are
pets.
I don't know what she would do if
someone decided that it was not a pet,
but lunch.
I think she would have a nervous
breakdown. And I don't think in heaven
there will be time for nervous
breakdowns. No, luckily not.
And so God used it as a test. Mhm.
And the interesting part about the test,
it has to do with discernment.
You see, that's the part that most
people don't understand. They only think
it's a physical
thing that it has to do with.
Yes, it has to do with circulation and
and the prevention of certain diseases.
But the greatest impact of diet is
discernment.
It's the mindset. That is the greatest
this
uh impact. And then also spirituality.
Mhm.
Now, spirituality can come from a
positive source and it can come from a
negative source.
But either way,
diet enhances spirituality
if it is done correctly.
So, many religions practice a vegetarian
diet and some even a very strict vegan
diet.
And I think of Hinduism, for example,
Jainism, Mhm. Buddhism.
Now, the stricted strictest of those
three is Jainism.
Jainism actually propagates total
veganism. Yeah. They will go so far as
to destroy
nothing, not even a mosquito. Mhm.
So, that's the one the one side of the
issue.
And then also in the esoteric world,
Mhm. people practice vegetarianism
and strict veganism as well
to enhance their spirituality.
Yeah.
I remember my father-in-law was into
occultism and if he wanted to have an
OOBE, an out-of-body experience, then he
would switch to vegetarianism
in order to better achieve that.
Mhm.
And so many of the high occultists are
vegan. Yeah.
And there are many books written on it
and there are authors that came out of
the Christian world, one of them being
an Anglican priest that became an
occultist and a medium. Mhm. And he
writes many books on the advantages of
this kind of diet, going back to what it
was like in Eden.
Eden. Mhm.
But of course, for an ulterior religious
experience.
But truth and error always run parallel.
Yeah.
That's it.
Because the devil is a copycat. And the
line is so thin, it's a hairbreadth.
Yes, and he says to the modern New Age
channels,
he says, "My children,
it is not necessary for you to eat
meat."
And that's why the whole New Age
movement is based on
a vegetarian diet.
So, what are the advantages? Why should
it be done? And we're being quite
provocative because we're going to quote
quite a
few statements from the writings of
Ellen G. White. Mhm.
And anybody can take those writings and
compare them with scripture and see if
they are in harmony with each other.
So, the biblical principles are plain.
We also have stories like Daniel, for
example,
That's it.
where this became a test. Mhm.
And it became a test of whether you want
to be in harmony with God's will or not.
Mhm.
And this is a very common feature in the
Bible.
In the beginning, diet was a test. In
the case of Daniel, which is a literal
story, but also a typological story,
taking you through to the end.
Diet was a very prominent component.
The children of Israel going out of
Egypt,
That's it. diet was a very prominent
component. Linked to the commandments,
the manna. And you're right. Now, if the
book of Genesis
was the book of beginnings
and the book of the fall,
and the book of Revelation is the
antithesis, is the book of restoration.
If diet was a test there, do you think
it should be a test in the last days?
I'm sure even Jesus, the first
temptation that Satan
put towards him in the wilderness, was
the same temptation
where he did not fail, but where Adam
and Eve failed. Yes. Once again, it was
according to diet. And why did why did
Eve want to take the forbidden fruit? In
order to achieve a higher state of
consciousness. Yes.
But it led to a fall.
And she looked at it and it looked good
for food. Now, where was the real true
higher state of consciousness? With God.
And in the diet that she had, that God
had prescribed, that was the food for a
higher state of consciousness. The other
one is a spurious state of
consciousness.
Exactly. So, she listened to someone
other than God, whether it is a demon or
whether it is a human being.
I think I want to read something out of
scripture.
And if you turn to Isaiah chapter 29
Well, we can actually read from verse 9.
Stay yourselves and wonder.
Cry ye out and cry, they are drunken but
not with wine.
They stagger but not for with strong
drink.
Here are people staggering from one text
in the Bible to the other and they just
don't get it.
Why don't they get it?
What is blocking their cognitive
ability?
For the Lord has poured out upon you the
spirit of deep sleep.
And has closed your eyes, the prophets
and your rulers, the seers
has he covered.
Now that is God's permissive will. God
doesn't darken your understanding ever.
He wants to enlighten your
understanding.
But your own activity has so blocked out
God that in the Jewish thinking if God
permits something, he enables it.
But these are the consequences.
Now the last church on earth, isn't it
called Laodicea? That's it.
Now isn't it a sleepy church?
Yes, lukewarm. It's lukewarm.
And they're fast asleep.
If you look at the parable of the
virgins, weren't they asleep? Yeah. They
were asleep.
And the vision of all is become unto you
the words of a book that is sealed.
You just don't understand anything.
Which men deliver to one that is learned
saying, "Read this, I pray thee." And he
says, "I cannot for it is sealed."
So you can give it to someone and say,
"Look, here it stands."
Mhm. Well, I don't get it.
I just don't get it.
Exactly.
And this is the original diet? Mhm. God
says, "It was not so in the beginning."
All their attempts to bring you back to
the original the I don't get it.
get it. I don't get it.
And the book is delivered to him that is
not learned. Mhm. Saying, "Read this, I
pray thee." And he says, "I'm not
learned."
So there are two excuses. The one is, "I
just don't get it. I can't understand
it." And the other one is, "I'm not even
going to try because I'm not educated
enough." Yeah.
And either one gets you into trouble.
Yeah.
The Bible is an amazing book, isn't it?
It's got something for everybody. Well,
I was isn't it thinking that's not the
there's another portion that's very um
applicable to our time. And that is John
the Baptist. Absolutely.
He was a total plant-based diet, honey
and locusta.
Mhm. The carrot bean. And he was the
type. And he was the type, the
anti-typical Elijah. So who's that?
And who's the anti-typical Elijah today?
The one who brings the same message,
makes straight the way for the Lord
and return. That's it. Return to what?
How it was in the beginning. How it was
in the beginning. So let's look at this
issue of health reform in the last days.
And we will be discussing a number of
quotes and
then people can look at them and see if
they're in harmony with the Bible.
1 Corinthians 10:31.
Wherefore therefore you eat or drink or
whatever you do, do all to the glory of
God.
Now what in God's glory is his
character? That's it. The law is
entrenched in this.
Death.
How did that come into the world?
Because of sin.
The transgression of the law. So in the
beginning was there any death?
No.
So I wonder how Adam felt when the first
little lamb was offered?
I think if I remember correctly, even
the when the first leaf dead leaf fell
Yeah. he was devastated. Devastated. He
should come to our area in the middle of
winter and you'll think it is
a nuclear site.
It is. Yeah. Yeah. And then spring
comes. That's the hope of resurrection,
right?
So let's look at light given. This comes
from Testimonies volume 9. There are
some professed believers who accept
certain portions of the testimonies as
the message of God
while they reject those portions that
condemn their favorite indulgences.
Such persons are working contrary to
their own welfare and the welfare of the
church.
It is essential that we walk in the
light while we have the light. Those who
claim to believe in health reform and
yet work counter to its principles in
the daily life practice are hurting
their own souls and are leaving wrong
impressions upon the minds of believers
and unbelievers.
Is this a problem
in the churches? Oh, definitely.
How serious is it that you practice what
you preach?
You have to practice what you preach.
Now what if
if people begin to understand this
and they come into a situation where the
people just don't adhere to any of the
principles, it doesn't create a good
impression, right?
It's a very sad situation. Um if you
work because normally you have a lot of
opposition
in this
field.
Yeah. So if you are doing Bible studies
or giving getting people to
understand how our message works and
this is part of the message
Yeah.
and you get them just barely to start
understanding and then you take them to
church and people do the opposite, it
really puts that whole effort that you
had back
months or even years. Okay. Let's be a
little bit provocative.
Does everybody or at least should
everybody in the churches know about the
health reform issue? Yes, I believe so
because
it is the right arm of the gospel.
And because it is agitated and there's
so much irritation about it, they
definitely all know about it.
I wonder whether they ask themselves the
question sometimes
if it is known and it is known to be
God's will
but I choose not to do it.
Am I placing a stumbling block in the
road or in the way of those who are
willing to accept it?
I wonder if they think about it because
They think they are placing a stumbling
block?
I know definitely. I know that's
happening but I like you mentioned, I
wonder if they ever think about it. Now
if they should think about it and they
are placing stumbling blocks
uh how do you think
God would feel about that? Yeah.
If he has given the message
and they know that he has given the
message because it's clearly depicted in
the Bible and they choose to ignore it
and place stumbling blocks in the road
and in the way of people that want to
embrace it
then surely God is not pleased with the
situation.
he's very sad.
Okay.
The Lord has given his people a message
in regard to health reform. This light
has been shining upon this their pathway
for 30 years.
Martin, this is long time ago. So we can
add at least a century to that.
This was 1897. 1897.
That is terrible.
And the Lord cannot sustain his servants
in a course which will counteract it.
Can he be pleased when half of the
workers laboring in the place teach that
the principles of health reform are as
closely allied to the third angel's
message as the arm is to the body to
have their co-workers by their practice
teach principles that are entirely
opposite? Didn't we just say that?
Exactly. How can you have two streams or
or you have the same message but two
people adhere to it in two two different
ways? Okay.
Now I've often met people that say to
me, "God is still patient with me. So he
allows me to do this and that until one
day I will be convinced."
Now my question is so if God had the
same patience with me drinking, would
that would be so also okay? So if you
came into the church imbibing in a
bottle of whiskey daily Yeah, and say
everybody would be up in arms, right?
And then then I would say I'll continue
like this because God has not shown me
yet. He's still
working on me so I can carry on till he
shows me it's now time to finish.
Let's just make it quite clear again. We
are quoting Ellen G. White here.
But we could just as well do it from the
Bible.
So, this is not disharmonious.
And it's logical.
So, the light which God has given upon
the health reform cannot be trifled with
without injury to those who attempt it.
And no man can hope to succeed in the
work of God while by precept and example
he acts in opposition to the light which
God has sent.
Those are incredibly
serious words.
You cannot succeed.
You can apparently succeed.
Because the devil has ways and means to
soothe your conscience.
Oh, for sure.
He's very good at that. Yes. Surely this
is not going to do this, that, or the
other to me. Cannot be so serious. God
is not so is not so particular. No.
You can go and pick up some sticks to
on the Sabbath day in those days, right?
And just because it doesn't happen today
because we're not living under
theocracy,
therefore it's never going to happen,
right?
I read that uh
God's footsteps
are very soft.
But he's constantly walking amongst us
with his Holy Spirit, right? Through his
Holy Spirit.
And those those footsteps and that voice
is a still small voice.
It's not a thunderbolt.
He's not in the earthquake. He's not in
the fire. He's not in the wind. But it
definitely is in the still small voice.
So, just because that voice is a small
still voice,
is it safe to ignore it? No, it's very
dangerous.
Now, what if that voice gets softer
and softer until you don't even hear it
anymore? That's very dangerous again.
I think we're already in trouble, but
seeing we are in trouble, let's
continue.
So, if we look at our screen picture at
the back here, and you have all of those
dietary issues on the left there, and
people fleeing to the right,
we could add some grains and some
legumes and things on the on the right
there to
you know, to bulk it up.
But it looks so inviting on the right.
It looks so perverted on the left.
And nevertheless,
people rather stay on the left.
Okay.
Letters and Manuscripts volume 12, no
man, woman, or child who fails to use
all the powers God has given him can
retain his health.
He cannot conscientiously keep the
commandments of God. He cannot love God
supremely and his neighbor and as
himself. My turn.
Can you imagine telling this to some
people?
They will
it does not go off well. They'll
disintegrate or explode. Because one of
the problem is they think you are
attacking and judging them.
And in the meanwhile,
it's a plea again like we've mentioned
in numerous
um episodes.
The commandments and all of this is not
an attack by God on you. And it's not a
means to your salvation, it's a
consequence. It's a consequence. So,
this is the same.
It's an outflow of your relationship
with God.
So, if you do not use all the powers God
has given you to retain your health,
you cannot conscientiously keep the
commandments of God.
But the characteristics of God's people
is that they keep the commandments of
God and hold to the testimony of Jesus.
That's it.
So, you mean to tell me that some cannot
do it because they are failing in some
particular areas?
Okay, let's go to the next quote.
The medical missionary field is open
before us. This work we begin to
comprehend better.
The light given us years ago that health
reform principles would be as an
entering wedge to be followed by a
religious influence.
So, you start with health.
You convince
through facts and circumstances and
scripture that this is God's way. You
bring them to the church
and they are shocked out of their wits.
Right? So, remember we had one person
come in and say
when he sees these things in the church,
he turns right round and walks out
again. And he gives a good reason. And
he gives a good reason because all the
things that are definitely wrong
are so prevalent. But the point that he
wants to wants to make through that is
that you don't take your religion
serious.
Exactly. So, it's very important how how
we look at these things. If you are
admonished by God not to drink and
smoke,
and you come to a place where they drink
and smoke,
do you take your religion seriously?
If you partake in it, you definitely
don't take your religion seriously. And
you can always use the difference in
approach as a lesson.
And some people believe they must
compromise in order to be winsome.
I'm glad you mentioned this. Because
it's a big stumbling block. How do you
treat people when you for instance go
are invited to go and visit?
And you have a certain lifestyle,
and they put on the table things that
you don't partake of in your lifestyle.
Then you will We did that sometimes in
the past. We
we said to the people, "Don't worry,
we'll eat everything
that we can, and you don't have to
stress about us at all."
Now, normally when it comes to the meat
issue, they do stress about it.
But you just calmly
explain to them why,
and then do the best you can without
violating your conscience one little
bit. Then they can become interested and
ask why. If you compromise, then it
doesn't matter. Then you can keep on
compromising. So, if you My My point is
if you compromise there,
and eventually those people get
interested, and they come with you into
the faith,
then they come and they find out now you
actually compromised.
They're not going to be very happy. It's
the same like I've mentioned before with
music and all of this. You cannot win
people with something that's not the way
you've compromised, and then you want
them to change once you've gained them.
And especially
when you
compromise on direct like for instance
clean and unclean. Yes.
So, you cannot say, "Okay, but if they
put on the table some of the things that
I don't usually partake,
but
it's at least
it's clean.
Yeah?
But what if it's unclean? There is no
such thing as a clean animal anymore in
my opinion.
Even if they are
organically raised as people say
in your backyard. We have so many viral
diseases and so many bacterial diseases
that are trans
uh
generic. In other words, they jump the
species barrier.
That nothing today is safe anymore
because disease is increasing in
proportion to the wickedness of man.
Here's another quote. Letter 57, your
interest and effort are to be given not
to the health question alone, but to
making known the truths of these last
times.
Truths that are deciding the destiny of
souls.
Some people go to the opposite extreme
and then make the health reform their
religion. That's it. They're on soapbox.
That's the only thing that they talk
about.
Now, that that's something you have to
avoid as well, right? No,
you see the problem that happens is it
will we can be labeled
on that.
The way that people perceive us because
we bring this message across.
They will say, you constantly talk about
this health and diet. this and that and
the other.
If they If you look at the balance of
our presentations, it's three angels'
message based, going into biblical
prophecy with the right arm of the
gospel. We We give the complete message
the whole time. So, it cannot be
severed. Is this how Jesus operated?
Same. Same way?
All right, the other point is
that it is a common sense message.
It just is based on common sense. And if
you if you look at the literature, and
you look at the media today, I mean the
literature is overwhelming that a
plant-based diet is healthier for you
than a diet based on animal protein.
The principles of health reform have the
highest authority and deserve a wider
sphere than has yet been given them by
many who profess present truth.
So, even though it is the arm and not
the body, it is a very important
principle.
God's way is to make man something he is
not. God's plan is to set man to work on
reformatory lines.
Then he will learn by experience how
long he has pampered fleshly appetites
and ministered to his own temperament
bringing weakness upon himself.
It's a logical issue.
So once you transform your
dietary
attributes,
then you can transform your spiritual
attributes. They are linked together.
If the health message is linked to a
spiritual message, then there must be a
link on that level as well, right?
It has to be.
Because why would even the occult world
do it?
There are those who have stood directly
in the way of the advance of health
reform. They have held the people back
by their indifferent
deprecatory remarks and their supposed
pleasantries and jokes.
Had all walked unitedly in the light
from the time it was first given on the
subject, there would have been an army
of sensible arguments employed to
vindicate the work of God.
But it has been by the most aggressive
movements that any advance has been
made.
Now,
this is a very sad
portion of the year.
Even by joking Mhm. about it, That's it.
you are putting a damper on it.
Yeah.
You you're building a wall. You're
building a wall.
So Martin,
you cannot divorce the spirituality from
the physical reality.
They are interlinked.
And if God says something in the Bible,
you cannot ridicule it Yeah.
and make it less prominent by starting
to joke about it.
Because it's very very serious.
Sometimes it's a matter of life and
death.
And I'm sure
Eve thought, well, surely it's not such
a big deal. Mhm. I'm sure. But take of a
little fruit and after all that serpent
seems to be doing quite well. Mhm. And
look at him. He can speak and he's
talking intelligent things and he's
promising me all kinds of wonderful
things, so
can't be all bad.
Again, if it's very important, then
there is the danger of going to
extremes.
That's it. But it's like all of this.
We've spoken about the soap boxes. We
had a whole lecture on it. As soon as
you take something and that becomes your
religion
or the only thing you focus on, then
you've you've lost the rest of the
message.
Okay. So they are very balanced
statements and that's what I like about
these writings.
Testimonies for the church volume two,
health reformers above all others should
be careful to shun extremes.
Now Martin, shunning extremes, is that a
license to cross the edges?
No.
Okay.
All are bound by the most sacred
obligations to God to heed the sound
philosophy
and genuine experience which he is now
giving them in reference to health
reform.
He designs that the great subject of
health reform shall be agitated
and the public mind deeply stirred to
investigate.
So it must be agitated. What happens
when you start agitating this at the
church level sometimes?
What what happens?
I I know exactly what happens. They tell
you, do you want to split the church?
Yes. Mhm.
I had this one guy come up to me and
scream at me and say, I eat meat.
See if I care. So what? You know, you're
quite welcome to exercise your choice,
but what made him so angry?
You know, you can just pitch up at a
barbecue.
Just they know what your diet is. And
you you're just physically present, but
you're not partaking.
And already they're coming towards you
and and attacking.
Attacking or telling you why and this
and that. I didn't say Then you don't
haven't even said a word yet. Or they'll
start joking. Yeah. And where's your
bananas that we can put it on the fire?
Or a carrot or A carrot or
get hungry when you mow the lawn?
Okay, do not catch hold of isolated
ideas and make them a test criticizing
others who practice may not agree with
your opinion, but study the subject
broadly and deeply.
There are people that go on a tangent
and then they will make certain issues
so prominent and it becomes so
complicated
that you shun the whole issue
altogether. Do not eat anything that
grows above the ground with things that
grow below the ground. Do not eat
anything that is yellow together with
something that is red. Do not do and the
list goes on and on and on. You you had
a story about somebody that was eating
orange peels. Yes, it I I was giving a
lecture somewhere in in Europe
and I was telling about the advantages
of the various fruits
and he kept interjecting and saying what
the advantage was of everything that we
normally discard like the skins.
And he did this about five, six, seven
times and eventually I said to him, you
know, you and I would be perfect
roommates.
I'll eat the orange, you eat the skin.
Yeah, so that's part of this um going to
extremes, isolating ideas and all of
this. By the way, you can use the skins
to add zest and all of these things.
That's all part of it.
It can be a holistic thing, but don't go
and be extreme about it. Oh, you should
only actually eat this and I knew a
person who said you may only eat five
nuts. Yeah, that's it.
And so they would count them out and you
would have five.
Or you're only allowed to eat 10
raisins.
And you would get 10 raisins.
And then
you would put it in the porridge,
but you were allowed to put nothing else
that is a a sweet in it. So it was very
difficult to eat it because you only had
10 spoons with one
It gets so so complicated. So avoid
extremes at all costs, but the basic
principles
stay the same. Yeah. Meat should never
appear on the table. Cheese is totally
unfit for food.
Mhm. It should never be introduced into
the human stomach. We can give all the
scientific facts as to why. But there
are are numerous lectures on that. But
there's no compromise that's possible
there.
The lack of stability in regard to the
principles of health reform is a true
index of their character and their
spiritual strength. Because it is a
subject that is so debated
and so
people are so fervent about it, shows
you that there must be something
important in it, right?
When we adopt the health reform, we
should adopt it from a sense of duty,
not because somebody else has adopted
it.
In other words, you must make it your
own.
That's it. You Once again, it must be
your free will, your choice that you've
made. Why do you keep the Sabbath?
Exactly the same
else discovered it? No, and not because
I want to get saved.
But it says in the Bible, remember the
Sabbath day to keep it holy. Six days
shall you labor and do all your work.
But the seventh day is the Sabbath of
the Lord your God. On it you shall not
So you're doing it because you're
convinced that this is really from God
and it makes sense to keep it because
you are acknowledging his authority.
Acknowledging his authority, if you go
to the first commandments,
don't have any other gods be before me
because you will suffer. So I've
realized that. I've gone gotten in a
relationship and love God. And that's
why I want to do these other things.
Okay, if that applies to the Sabbath,
didn't you say the same things about
health reform?
The same.
So when you start investigating it,
is it always easy?
No. No, right? Nothing is easy because
we're living in a world full of sin. Is
it easy to stop smoking if you're a
smoker?
No, I think
it's drinking, smoking. You can name all
of it.
All of it is something that you indulge
in.
And food is one of But if it's bad for
you, you want to give it up. Some people
give it up because they know it's bad
for them.
Now, how much more incentive if you know
that your body is the temple of the Holy
Spirit and God wants it to be
clean.
So Martin, would you say that health
reform is an educational process?
Yes. It doesn't happen overnight.
So we need patience, right?
And we should not be judgemental, right?
But we should be winsome.
Now, sometimes just being a health
reformer makes you an enemy without
doing anything else. That's it. Just you
just doing that.
In reforms, we would better come one
step short of the mark than go one step
beyond it.
That's an amazing statement. In other
words, do not be so extreme
that people are people are put off.
So,
you know, if they really want to eat
five nuts only,
then be an absolute extremist and go to
six.
Or fall one
one step short. No, we shouldn't mock
them,
but we should be careful to avoid all
extremes.
And we must go no faster than we can
take those with us whose conscience and
intellects are convinced of the truths
we advocate.
We must meet the people where they are.
And this is something that the people
misunderstand about Jesus.
Jesus said,
"The Son of Man came eating and
drinking."
And they accused him of being with
publicans and sinners, etc.
And John the Baptist came not eating and
drinking. In other words, strictly
adhering to the principles.
Now, when Jesus met the people where
they are,
did he go
across that line which would have
been sin? No.
He never crossed that line. Never.
Because he was sinless.
But he met the people where they are.
Did he go to meet the people just to
mingle and associate with them? Or did
he have a message to bring them out?
He also gave them the gospel.
But then he gave information
through typology in the Bible
and through prophets that a time will
come when certain things have to stop
and can no longer be practiced.
And that is where the important part is.
You have to start realizing as well. We
have to meet the people, and the people
has to realize you meet them there. But
you cannot stay there. There's a time
coming where you have to go to the other
side.
Would it be useful to have in the time
that we live in attention deficit
disorder?
Would it be useful for you, or would you
rather prefer to have all your
discernment?
Yes, all my discernment.
Now, what if the literature tells you
that heavy metal pollution
that occurs, for example, in fish today
is a contributing factor
to a lower cognitive function
in a broad spectrum of humanity?
And what if there was a warning sign,
"No fishing."
And the guy is standing next to it with
his rod.
Water polluted. Mercury poison in the
water.
Now, in the old days, you had a
profession called the hatter.
People who made hats.
And there's an expression in English
which says, he's as mad as a hatter.
Because the matter went insane. The
hatter went insane.
And why did he go insane? Because in
preparing the hats, they used mercury.
And he breathed in this mercury all the
time, and he became insane. He was as
mad as a hatter.
Now, if this is a dietary issue in the
times that we live in, was it a dietary
issue in the time of Jesus? No. No, it
wasn't a dietary issue. So, if Jesus ate
a fish
because it was permitted, a clean fish
from the Sea of Galilee,
there was no cognitive impairment as a
consequence, right?
Now, what if he said the time will come
when this will no longer be safe, and I
do not want you to partake in it at all?
Can you then use him as an example to do
it?
him as an example why you should still
be able to continue it and stand with
your fishing rod next to a polluted
environment?
Because you're disregarding what he
said. Let's rest our case. We don't have
to read the whole rest of this quote.
The greatest objection to health reform
is that this people do not live it out.
How many people have come or we we
mentioned it the other day. When you
meet some people that you know in the
supermarket, what's the first thing they
do?
They look into your trolley. To see if
you are living if there's anything there
that is untoward. Now, if there were
something, how embarrassed would you be?
Oh, yes, of course.
Okay.
Trying to get the trolley away. So, you
have to
You have to practice what you preach.
When you walk down the aisle and
somebody eyes you and you go this side,
There was a church
that refused to listen to anything that
I had to say anymore
because they discovered, so they
thought, that I was a liar.
And so I did some gentle inquiring as to
what I had said that had so offended
them.
The fact of the matter is, I'd said
nothing other than what I normally say.
But they saw me in a pizzeria.
In a restaurant.
eating a pizza.
And they automatically assumed that that
pizza must have cheese on it. Therefore,
I was a hypocrite.
But they never bothered to come and look
what was on my pizza.
So,
it's a very important thing
that you practice what you preach.
That's it. And it's also important the
same that you expect of somebody else.
Because that this easy, quick to judge.
Yes. Make sure. The same with us. It's
everybody. Before you jump to
conclusions,
I mean, assumption is always a problem.
So, guilt rests upon us who as a people
have had much light
because we have not appreciated or
improved the light given upon health
reform. This is not a matter to be
trifled with, to be passed off with a
jest.
I virtually hear a jest about it every
time I come in contact with a group of
believers. There will always be someone
who jests about it.
In God's eyes, it's not a trifling
matter. Don't jest.
The other important point about health
reform in the last days. Why is it so
important,
particularly in the last days?
Well, number one, the environment has
been destroyed.
Number two, the
animals and the animal kingdom is
polluted. People say to me, "But the
plants are also sprayed with poisons."
So, what's the difference? Or they will
also say to you,
"A grass-fed
antelope
is better than a GMO-modified
corn."
arguments like that.
Now, that antelope, even if he is in the
wild, is riddled with diseases that
didn't exist
a few decades ago.
And some of those diseases are
transferable
and can cause extreme debilitating
diseases.
Now, it might happen rarely,
but it does happen.
The other point is, plants that are
sprayed are normally sprayed with
surface poisons.
They're not systemic poisons.
Now, if that spray spreads to a
grassland a few kilometers away where
there are cows grazing,
those cows internalize that poison.
Whereas, when you go and get the
vegetables
and you don't know where they sprayed it
or not,
you wash them.
Now, many times when a farmer sprays and
it rains that evening, he's most upset
because he has to spray again, right?
So, it's not a systemic poison. Plants
aren't very good at taking up organic
matter.
And most of the toxins are
organo-poisons.
So, they take up their minerals and
water, and they produce their organic
material from photosynthesis.
So, if I take the plant and I wash it,
then I've done what I can. That's it.
Whereas, when the cow eats that grass,
even if the concentration of the toxin
is reduced by a thousand times
through the process of biological
magnification,
because the cow continues to eat on a
daily basis, those toxins are
accumulated and end up in the tissues,
particularly the fat.
Now, God even made provision for that.
He said, "Don't eat the fat."
And the blood.
But, if you season the fat and you you
put it on the barbecue, it it is so
delightful and so flavorsome because of
all those toxins that's in it.
So, you're still better off with a plant
even in a bad environment and you have
to live.
So, the motto that I have adopted is do
what you can and leave the consequences
to God. That's true. The one extreme
that I go to is I plant my own
vegetables. Yeah.
And if I have to use something to deter
the insects, it will be a natural thing
like neem oil
uh in a little bit of a soap solution.
All right, let's have a look at the
spirituality concept.
Satan knows that he cannot overcome man
unless he can control his will.
He can do this by deceiving man so that
he will cooperate with him in
transgressing the laws of nature.
She's not only talking about the law of
God here. She's talking about the laws
of nature, the laws of your physical
being.
Mhm.
Anything that lessens the physical
power, enfeebles the mind and makes it
less clear
to discriminate between good and evil,
between right and wrong.
You remember we showed a video a couple
of
well, a lot of WhatsApps
ago
where we showed the effect of drinking
one cup of coffee, just one cup of
coffee
and where I did the brain scans and saw
that your oxygen supply, your blood
supply, particularly to your frontal
lobes was reduced by 40%.
That's it.
40% reduced capacity, one cup.
Uh would it be easier for the devil to
use that occasion to plant some
diabolical seed in your mind? What is
the most popular drink in the world?
Coffee.
So, let's say
70% of the world's population
goes to work in the morning with a 40%
less brain activity.
Oh, that's a very dangerous point.
So, the principles of health reform
which are adopted by him who gives word
of God to others will have a molding
influence upon his work
and upon those with whom he labors. If
his principles are wrong,
he can misrepresent the truth to others.
Didn't we just read that in the Bible?
In Isaiah.
If he accepts the truth which appeals to
reason rather than to perverted
appetite,
his influence for the right will be
decided.
It's a very important point, the
spirituality.
What if you ignore it?
Then unfortunately, that small voice
will just start growing softer. Okay.
The Review and Herald.
One reason why we do not enjoy more of
the blessings of the Lord,
we do not heed the light which he has
been pleased to give us in regard to the
laws of life and health.
It is not possible for us to glorify God
while living in violation of the laws of
life.
That's a
very profound statement. It's a
controversial
It's not possible.
But, I Martin, so many people
demonstrate that they believe that it is
possible.
All who profess to be followers of Jesus
should feel that a duty rests upon them
to preserve their bodies in the best
condition of health. That's one aspect.
That their minds may be clear to
comprehend heavenly things. Can you
separate the two from each other?
No.
If you are
in the drug world
and you are taking marijuana or you are
taking mushrooms,
I'm talking about hallucinatory
mushrooms.
If you are partaking in the drug world
or if you are partaking in the so-called
harmless drugs like caffeine
and all of these stimulants that you
find in smart drinks, etc., etc.
Uh will it
uh affect your comprehension?
Of for sure. And then you cannot discern
spiritual things.
The Bible tells us that and the spirit
of prophecy. The problem is people that
let's take caffeine for instance.
Some people will tell you, "No, but I
need it so that I can concentrate." No.
It gives you a lift and then it gives
you a complimentary
free
gift
of
of a total letdown often leading to
depression. You see, the problem is that
same video we were talking about also
showed that once you drink your used to
drink the caffeine,
that your normal level is down here. So,
then only to get back to normal is when
you drink the caffeine.
Then you're back to
But, it's only an illusion. Exactly.
It's not as you think you have more
energy in your in your muscles,
but your cognitive capacity
is impaired.
Every wrong habit which injures the
health of the body reacts in effect upon
the mind.
Those things which fret and derange the
stomach will have a benumbing influence
upon the finer feelings of the heart.
Now, the heart is your is your
the portion where your character, your
morality is portrayed in.
So, in other words, your character is
affected by the stomach.
Now, it's very interesting that in the
scientific world,
it has been
made very clear and it's become a very
important part of scientific research
that the stomach and your intestines
have a mind of their own. Yeah, it's got
a brain. They have a brain.
And the communication between the
stomach and the brain is of absolute
paramount importance. Yeah. Even the
stuff that you just put on your tongue
sends signals to the brain which in turn
induce the release of certain substances
that are required to deal with that
issue.
So, the link between the stomach and the
brain
scientifically has been proven beyond
doubt. Mess with the stomach,
mess with the brain.
And the mind, depression, anxiety.
That's why she says, "The gloom and
despondency supposed to be the result of
obedience to God's moral law is often
attributable
to a disregard of physical law. If you
cannot understand it,
if you think it is a burden,
it is because you are deranged in your
diet and thinking."
Unless they practice true temperance,
they will not they cannot be susceptible
to the sanctifying influence of truth.
Now, let's just analyze that. Martin,
does that mean that you cannot read the
truth and maybe even understand the
truth? No.
But, you cannot have the sanctifying
influence applied to it.
The portion that's supposed to change
you.
Okay. For the better. So, some people
know the truth. Some people can quote
the truth. But, if they don't live the
truth,
then they are not sanctified by it.
Eating and drinking and dressing all
have a direct bearing upon our spiritual
advancement. Now, now it gets
complicated.
And now you want to pull out the last
hairs that you still have.
Martin,
how can the way you dress
affect your spirituality?
It's about the
portraying God's character again.
All right. So, if you dress
in order to glorify yourself,
are you then in juxtaposition to the
will of God?
Yes.
So, you mean to tell me dress can affect
your spirituality? Definitely. If
If If a If a young lady wears a dress
that is more akin to a belt than a
dress,
then spirituality of everybody who
perceives it goes right out the window,
right?
You see, it links on to the same things
that we've just spoken about diet.
Exactly the same can be applied to
dress. Well, let's not irritate our
viewers too much.
No, but we must remember
we've read also there the extremes. Yes.
So, we must be very careful in all these
things that we don't go to extremes.
All right. So, when it comes to dress
reform, if you go to extremes and you
stand out like a
sore thumb, you will be ridiculed and
the truth you hold will be ridiculed
with it.
So, do not go so far as to be beyond
redemption on that part, but do not go
to the other extreme either. So,
somewhere there is a nice middle way.
There's a lot of counsel from the spirit
of prophecy. Okay.
So, morality
and diet and the way you dress, all of
these things are interconnected and
cannot readily be separated.
So, by indulging in a wrong course of
action in eating and drinking, thousands
upon thousands are ruining their health
and not only is their health ruined,
but their morals are corrupted because
diseased blood flows through their
veins.
Your morals are corrupted by what you
eat. The lower passions are stimulated.
Yeah.
I'm sure you know, Martin, that music
can do the same.
Exactly. Yeah, for sure. Mhm.
So, when you go to a party
and it is now
time for the morals to be corrupted,
whereas before there was music to put
you into a hyped stage
and maybe
encourage the imbibing of certain liquid
beverages,
then it is time to bring in another
modulation
in the music to change the tempo and the
rhythm.
And does that affect the morals, yes or
no?
sure.
And the same happens with food.
You mentioned, I think it was in the
lecture path to obedience,
what the effect of
cacao is. Yes. Of theobromine that you
find in the cocoa products.
So, in chocolate.
And especially when it is given to the
ladies.
That's it. So, why, and you explained in
there, it's very effective on
Valentine's Day.
Aha. And that's why it's a very
prominent present.
But
that dear little Valentine,
if I may call him such an endearing
name, has a very corrupting influence.
So, overeating prevents the free flow of
thought and words.
So, it's not only what you eat, it's the
quantity that you consume.
Because if you eat too much, you have
this heavy feeling with your droopy
eyes. And when you have those droopy
eyes, is it possible to have hypnotic
influences exert their power over you?
Well, what about watching TV and
consuming, like people are
binge-watching series,
and they constantly
They're constantly eating because the
two go together.
Do you think they're very
uh
capable of making moral decisions under
those circumstances? Not according to
what we've just read.
All right. Excessive eating of even the
best of food will produce a morbid
condition
of the moral feelings. Wrong habits of
eating and drinking lead to errors in
thought and action. Indulgence of
appetite strengthens the propensities
given them
the ascendancy over the mental and
spiritual powers. Everything that
conflicts with natural law
creates a diseased condition of the
soul.
So, Martin, eating and drinking
is more linked to your moral attributes
and your discernment
than most people can even realize.
And that is where the big problem is.
I've always We've spoken about it in the
beginning.
It's not so much about your physical
well-being that God is concerned.
It's about your moral and cognitive.
Okay.
So, when he designed the diet that he
gives us,
which is so full, if you look at the
picture on the screen,
so full of antioxidants to make sure
that anything that can be debilitating
in terms of your cognitive function
is removed by antioxidants and
flavonoids and
compounds that will enhance brain
function. And that is the best food for
your brain, right?
By the way, the brain just consumes
simple carbohydrate. No protein.
Exactly.
So, if you want to enhance these noble
attributes of the soul, then you may not
be a slow slave to animal passions.
That is morally speaking and dietary
speaking.
If those who profess to be Christians
desire to solve the questions so
perplexing to them,
why their minds are so dull, why their
religious aspirations are so feeble,
they need not in many instances go
further than the table.
Here's a cause enough,
if there were no other.
I remember when I was in the world
and I was I was
educated person. I was uh
a lecturer at universities.
And when I had lunch,
Mhm.
then I would go and lie on the floor and
complain to my wife that I was feeling
dull.
I had to whip myself into activity to go
back to the university to go and give
the next classes.
Now, this dullness
is something that is a distant memory to
me since I've changed my diet. That's
true.
I mean, every Well, I used Well, we can
relate it to either Sunday or Sabbath.
After the big meal,
what's uh the first thing a lot of
people want to do? They want to have a
snooze.
A ceiling inspection. Yes. Now, why do
they want a ceiling inspection? Because
there's so much free fat circulating in
their veins
that the oxygen supply to the brain is
shut off.
And
uh you know, like in our country when
the electricity goes off, everything
else goes off as well.
And so, they just pass out.
Yeah.
So, the first uh circuit breaker is in
the stomach,
shuts off the electricity, and then the
brain will shut off automatically
afterwards. That's right. We call that
the graveyard portion. That's it. The
worst classes to give are those after
lunch.
A religious life can be more
successfully gained and maintained if
flesh meats are discarded.
How important is it in the last days to
develop a religious life?
Very important. Okay.
Children reared in a healthful way are
much more easily controlled
than those who are indulged in eating
everything their appetite craves and at
all times.
Children are being put on Ritalin
because they have too much energy and
can't net calm down.
Yes. But this tells me
They take restless leg syndrome to the
extreme.
Now, this has been proved in prisons, by
the way.
Putting prisoners, even
highly dangerous, violent prisoners
on this healthful diet
reduces the requirements for locking
them up in solitary confinement.
Yeah, wow. Isn't This has been proven.
This is a fact.
This is not a conjecture by by someone
that needs to be ignored. So, Martin,
let's talk about spirituality. And that
is why health inform health reform is so
important in the last days.
Now, these things that we have
at our disposal
were written by Ellen G. White.
And people will say, "Well,
I don't see it in that detail in the
Bible, therefore I will ignore it." But
the principles are in the Bible.
So, is it safe to ignore it? No.
No, the Lord requires a living sacrifice
of mind, soul, body, and strength. Is
that biblical?
Yes. That's what Doesn't Paul say so?
Exactly the same. Okay.
True sanctification is not merely a
theory and emotion
or a form of words, but a living active
principle
entering into the everyday life. It
requires that our habits of eating,
drinking, and dressing be such as to
secure the preservation of physical,
mental, and moral health,
that we may present to the Lord our
bodies not an offering corrupted by
wrong habits, but a living sacrifice
wholly acceptable unto God. That's a
biblical quote. It's so important. You
know, we all is here You always hear
people say, "We have to live
as Christ wants us to live and we must
love him."
But his message is all encompassing.
It's a holistic message.
Yes, it's not just in certain portions.
See, that's why he gave you health
reform in the Bible. I once, many years
ago, gave a sermon which I titled
optional accessories.
So, you buy some piece of equipment,
like you're buying a tool kit, for
example, that works with batteries, but
the batteries
can also accommodate other tools.
And those are then optional accessories.
So, you buy the main tool and then
then sometimes an optional accessory
becomes a necessary accessory and you
have to buy it.
Now, does it work like that in the
religious world? Does God give you a
plan of salvation
and tells you that you have to accept
the righteousness of Christ, but then he
gives you a whole bunch of optional
accessories?
You can choose whether you want to do
them or not. Does that work like that?
No. No. No. Are you sure? I'm What's
wrong with you? You're an extremist.
I'll rather go with fundamentalist. Oh.
That's what the word say.
Yes.
Okay.
So, in other words, true sanctification
is not merely a theory, an emotion, or a
form of words,
but a living active principle entering
into the everyday life.
It requires that our habits of eating
and drinking and dressing be such as to
secure the preservation of physical,
mental, and moral health. If it's
freezing outside, but you're absolutely
determined to display all your body
parts as far as is
allowable,
is this conducive to health?
No. Okay.
That we may present to the Lord our
bodies not an offering corrupted by
wrong habits. So, it's not just eating
and drinking, it's habits.
Are you going to now become discouraged
because the list is getting so long,
Martin? No, because
the list of everything in the Bible is
long. But, as long as you want to do it
because you have a relationship with
Jesus, it doesn't matter how long it is.
Now, when you first started to drive
your car,
were you an expert or did it sometimes
go
I don't know in
It seems like in other countries the
it's the the main um drive on the
gearbox is not a stick shift.
No. In South Africa, it is.
It is. So, you have to learn to use a
clutch and you have to learn to do these
things.
So, everything is out of sync when you
first start.
When you first start. But, once you
start getting used to it and those
pathways are created, then it becomes
automatic, right? You don't even think
about it anymore. Isn't it the same with
health reform? It's the same.
So, once you start doing it,
it becomes it becomes a habit.
A good habit. And once you have replaced
the bad habit with a good habit, in the
beginning it's a bit jerky. But,
everything is like that in life. There's
nothing that's just
easy.
And the interesting thing, Martin, is
everything that the world offers Mhm. is
the exact opposite of what is right.
That is easy. Um unfortunately, there is
some things in life that's that's easy.
But, most of the times that's things
that's not good for you. All right. Now,
if you take a massive football stadium
crowded with 80,000 spectators,
what are they serving while you are
watching this spectacle here in front of
you? Uh definitely not a few carrots and
What's on the left there, right? It's
And is alcohol involved? Oh, for sure.
Now, I know that some stadiums realized
that people go away there and there are
accidents and people actually die as a
consequence and then they they banned
the alcohol for a while.
And people brought in the alcohol
alcohol any which way possible.
In very creative ways. In very creative
ways and eventually they gave up on that
issue and returned back to the status
quo. Yeah.
So,
habits
that become ingrained
are normally bad habits.
Yeah.
So, can you ingrain good habits?
Yes, with God's help. Can the Can that
green smoothie in the morning actually
become a delight after a while?
Well, you'll have to tell me that.
Me? Yes. Why me?
enjoy the Did you enjoy your green
smoothies? It depends how green it was.
But, if if it was delightfully made with
lots of fruits and there was some green
with it, I would partake of it without
complaining.
But,
I I I just have to mention that when I
when you were
going through a rough patch with a
health the other day
and I came visiting, you said to me,
"No, your wife has gone and taken a
5,000 L
container and put everything that's
green in there and then came
it down my throat.
Yes, you can you can get rebellious when
it comes
to too much of a good thing.
But, if it is pleasant, then it becomes
part of your habitual life, in the end
you're wondering why you wanted
something perverted.
You know, when it starts
mattering
is when you don't have that. If you've
got if it became a habit and then for
some reason you go somewhere and you
don't have those
those products that are helpful to you,
then you realize, "Sure, I really need
it." Correct. So, it should ever be kept
prominent that the great object to be
attained through this channel is not
only health, but perfection and the
spirit of holiness.
That's incredible, isn't it?
A diseased body causes a disordered
brain and hinders the work of
sanctifying grace upon the mind and
heart. If you are constantly
in a state of agitation
or constantly depressed,
will you be able to
No. appreciate spirituality, let alone
holiness?
Let's just sit around with somebody
that's constantly negative or depressed
and see how much he saps the life out of
you as well.
It's like it's almost like a vampire.
Mhm.
Sometimes you come into the presence and
you are just sucked dry.
And why is it that people require these
things? You should actually be a ray of
light, right?
And not a sponge.
Yeah.
So, it has to do with sanctified
life. And you are sanctified through the
Health reform is part of the truth.
That's it.
So, if Christians obey the laws which
govern health and life, they will have
the blessing of physical and mental
bigger and they will have moral power to
engage in the warfare against Satan.
It's a complete package. If you go to
war,
Mhm.
would you like to leave half of your
armaments behind because they were
burden to you? That's going to give
problems to It's going to give you
problems.
So, many a sermon has received a dark
shadow from the minister's indigestion.
That's very well put.
He has a way with words
that I sometimes find delightful.
And this is one of the
One of those.
Many a sermon has received a dark shadow
from the minister's indigestion.
In order to render to God perfect
service, we must have a clear conception
of his will. And we cannot have it
if we don't accept the total plan.
All right. I think we must start
wrapping this discussion up. I I'm sure
it ruffled some feathers and say we're
trying to make something unimportant
prominent.
But, if it really was so important, why
have we had 6,000 years of calamity?
And it just got worse and worse and
worse. Because it started with that,
right?
God's way is to give man something that
he has not,
to make him something that he is not.
It's a hard process
because it's a total reversal of what
you were. And what you
the flesh
it's like Paul said, "What
my mind says I must do, my body does not
want to do." And your flesh tells you
something else.
Man's way is to get an easy place and
indulge appetite and selfish ambition.
God's plan is to set man at work in
reformatory lines and then he will learn
by experience how long he has tampered
with fleshly appetites and ministered to
his own temperament bringing weakness
upon himself.
He gives grace if the sick man realizes
that he needs it. God proposes to
purify, refine
the defiled soul and then he will
implant in the heart his own
righteousness and peace and health and
man will become complete in him.
If Christ rules in their hearts, they
are gaining strength of principle with
power and ability to stand as faithful
sentinels, true reformers. Then, like
Daniel, there you have the biblical
example again.
They make impressions upon others that
will never be affected and their
influence will be carried to all parts
of the world.
Isn't it interesting how God elevated
those
friends, Daniel and his three friends?
Yeah.
And they were the only ones in that
entire crowd
that adhered to the these principles. To
the principles and
did not bow to the image.
Now, Martin,
the basic problem of heaven
was pride and selfishness.
Yeah.
Right?
Mhm. Indulgence of appetite is actually
a form of selfishness.
Yeah, it is. It's what you want and what
not what is better for the greater good,
right?
So, it is the duty of those who have
received light upon this important
subject to manifest a greater interest
for those who are still suffering for
want of knowledge.
If you indulge very often, you cannot in
correct ways
reach others. That's it.
You might reach others,
but not in correct ways.
So, that's the that totally takes away
when you say, "But I have to go and
compromise to be able to reach
somebody."
Do occultists reach others? Yeah, very
much so. Do they lead them in the paths
of light or into the paths of
destruction? Destruction. Okay.
Those who are looking for the soon
appearing of their Lord
should be the last to manifest the lack
of interest in the great work of reform.
If you want to reach others,
you have to do what God says. And that
is the whole issue, Martin,
of health reform in the last days.
Do you as an individual want to be part
of the loud cry? Oh, for sure. You want
to be? Very much, yeah. I want to be,
too.
For a while there, I thought might be
impossible for me,
but I have hope that I can be part of
it.
It's impossible to do it, impossible,
Yeah.
if you do not accept the package.
In God's work, there are no optional
accessories.
It's a covenant.
And this book, Martin,
is a covenant
from the first page to the last.
Yeah.
What am I going to ignore? What's
essential for me? What portion of it is
essential?
The whole one. The whole one? Yeah. It's
all
or nothing. That's it. Not certain
parts.
So, let's leave it at that
and pray that God will impress minds
that something as simple as and mundane
as health reform
can be salvational.
Maybe I just want to highlight that
most people know, we've spoken about it,
you
your wife last year and this year you
had
a difficulty with health issues. Yes.
And both of you
got accused about your diet. Yes.
You got sick, but you got out and you're
sitting here and your wife is perfectly
ex- In fact, they said that she's in
pristine condition.
Yes. And you didn't change a thing. You
stayed on the course that God has given
us.
Well, that's kind of you, Martin.
The very thing that people claimed made
us sick
is the very thing that brought us back
to health and strength as well.
So, sometimes there are
uh certain issues that come from your
past. That's very important. And you
cannot always say that you will be
totally free of problems.
But if you stick to what God said,
then you have the highest probability
of uh recovering.
So, let's pray and ask God to enlighten
the minds of the people as to the
importance of health reform in the last
days. Let's pray.
Heavenly Father,
this point has been labored to such an
extent that it has become a bone of
contention.
And again and again and again we speak
about it because we have been instructed
to agitate the point.
And I pray, Lord, that it will be
received in the way in which it was
intended
to encourage people
to
walk these paths
so that their spirituality can come
in line with the requirements of the
word. This is my prayer in Jesus' name.
Amen. Amen.